fox news exclusive footage shows a surge
of migrants including young children
crossing the rio grande
in del rio texas as the local sheriff
says the situation at the border has
never been worse
it's tying up our resources it's
frustrating because there's no
no answers that are being given there's
not a
there's not i don't believe that there's
a plan in place right now you know we
need more manpower we need people in dc
to make a decision uh do it do their job
do their job here to react the guy who
did the job fox news contributor and
former acting
ice director tom homan tom good morning
good morning uh the videos show from our
reporter
uh bill malugen uh down there uh showed
these large groups of like 30 40 50
people a couple of them
uh groups of people from cuba and
venezuela as well
and they're just walking across at the
lowest time of the river and
the border patrol people and the
sheriff's
deputies are just right there helping
them remember in the old days when
the border patrol would stand on one
side and said hey no
turn around go the other way
absolutely when i was a border patrol
agent they either ran from you they hid
from here this is unbelievable
where we're at as a nation but look
they've been invited right joe biden
made promises
they won't be deported they won't be
detained they'll get free health care
he's going to shut down ice i mean these
people were invited and they're coming
and
and and what's really irritating steve
is the biden administration knows how to
stop this
but joe biden was vice president 1415
during the first search alejandro
mayorkas was a deputy secretary
i met with these men many times we they
know how we stopped him you know how we
stopped him we
built detention mr centers we detained
them long enough to see a judge they got
removal orders to remove them the
numbers went down
what they're doing now release them as
quick as possible without going to see a
court they're not even getting a court
date
they're getting a brand new cell phone a
brand new smartphone the compliments of
the taxpayers
get released for those with no court
date and i just can't remove them even
if they get order removed because ice
can't remove immigration offenders
anymore tom mayorkas on friday said the
border is closed you look at those
images the border is not closed
and it's a crisis but it is also an
invasion
look they're touting great success we
got it under control because
like i said weeks ago they're getting
really good at releasing people
as quick as possible so there doesn't
seem to be overcrowding at the border
facilities
meanwhile they're ignoring the border
and the thousands coming across
every day their action speaks louder
than the words
people in central america and all the
world seeing get united states
get released with no court date and
and interior enforcement's been gutted
ice will never remove you because you
have to commit an aggravated felony
for ice to even look at you this is open
borders agenda this is this is open
borders
and this is what the by administration
meant this is this is by design this
isn't by accident
you were talking about you've met with
my orchestra for many many times
uh uh somebody that people may not be
familiar with
is a woman by the name of natalie
monoliango she is the white house deputy
director for political strategy and
outrage and outreach and it is a little
outrageous actually
some of the things that she tweeted in
the past
for instance she tweeted this
administration's
actions are not motivated by public
safety concerns
they're terrorizing immigrant
communities ice didn't exist 15 years
ago
it doesn't have to exist now she's
talking about ice
and then about a month later in 2018 she
said
if you're looking for a way to help look
up your nearest ice office
and shut it down tom those are the words
of
a white house administration official
well news flash ice existed prior it was
called the immigration nationalization
service so we were enforcing immigration
law prior to ice
and guess what she doesn't i understand
what ice even does she probably got the
job because of that tweet
does she realize ice arrested aliens
commit 1800 homicides
over 10 000 sexual offenses i seized
over 1.4 million pounds of narcotics
they arrested over a thousand child
predators
that saved over three thousand children
do they realize they saved seven hundred
women from human trafficking
seized over seven thousand weapons she
has no idea what ice does
but she probably got the job because she
hates ice just like the vice president
compared ice to the kkk
that's how they got their job all right
tom homan joining us from virginia tom
thank you very much